[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur LCP dans
politique à table autour d'un plat d'un
invité et d'un dessert et notre invité
cette semaine c'est Corinne Vignon
bonjour bonjour avec moi pour présenter
cette émission Jean-Pierre Montanet
bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour Brigitte
Vignon
vous êtes député renaissance de
Haute-Garonne depuis 2017 vous avez
travaillé sur feu la retraite à points
lors du premier quinquennat et sur le
bien-être animal engagé tardivement en
politique vous êtes devenu maire de
Flourens près de Toulouse en 2014 mais
vous êtes plutôt touche-à-tout diplômé
de l'École Supérieure d'Art et de Design
de Reims vous devenez architecte
d'intérieur avant de partir au Costa
Rica construire un complexe
écotouristique avec des tortues 10 ans
plus tard vous devenez charcutier
traiteur et vous allez travailler comme
traiteur officiel du Barça et puis après
directrice commerciale d'Afflelou en
gros vous traversez la rue et vous
trouvez du boulot vous êtes sans doute
la plus macroniste de l'hémicycle
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidence
alors Corine Vignon cet espadon n'est
pas par hasard dans votre assiette
d'abord ça rime Vignon espadon mais vous
la défenseur red du bien-être animal
vous le vénérez ce poisson surnommé
poisson épais il incarne à vos yeux la
résistance animale la force contre les
gémonie de l'homme et oui son nom vient
du mot italien Spadone qui Brigitte veut
dire signifie grande épée l'épée qui
dans l'histoire et la mythologie
représente souvent l'arme suprême
Excalibur l'épée magique et légendaire
du roi Arthur Durandal les pays
mythiques qui auraient appartenu à
Roland le neveu de Charlemagne l'épée de
Brennus que se disputait César et pomper
puis plus près de nous les pélaser
inspirés de la mythologie dans la saga
Star Wars pour son épée donc en guise de
trophée l'espadon continue d'être traqué
par les pêcheurs qui adorent défier ce
prédateur qui peut peser Brigitte
jusqu'à une demi tonnes et mesurait 4
métaux mais dites moi Corinne Vignon
vous qui a dulé ce poisson comment
expliquer vous que vous acceptez encore
de le couper en darnes ou en tranches
pour le déguster
et bien écoutez d'abord parce que
j'adore j'adore l'espadon
très clairement alors oui bien sûr je
défends le bien-être animal mais cet
animal enfin l'espadon vit libre heureux
et la vie c'est aussi la mort donc il
est péché il y a une industrie de la
pêche que on défend ardemment même si
elle est vertueuse en tout cas et je
trouve que ce poisson est absolument
délicieux et il est extrêmement light et
moi je suis je suis très attention
pourquoi parce que vous faites très
attention à votre ligne depuis toujours
que je me suis dit très jeune je
garderai ma taille jusqu'à la retraite
et là pour l'instant je tiens la même
vêtements exactement je mets encore des
choses ça va attendre donc plus l'âge de
la retraite vous voilà
ça veut dire quoi jamais de dessert ou
très peu jamais alors en location
je me prive en permanence mais ceci dit
je suis ravi de mettre mes jeans de
il y a quelques années parce que un
petit cassoulet de temps en temps vous
le voyez tout de suite sur le sur le
pantalon vous savez quand on est en
privation quand on est très strict sur
le régime vous prenez un kilo dès que
vous mangez trois frites donc il y a
jamais d'écart et vous faites très
rarement je pense que je mange des
frites par exemple une fois par an dans
le meilleur des cas et donc vous avez
quoi d'autre de votre alimentation les
donc évidemment tous les gâteaux tout ce
qu'on adore en fait j'ai banni tout ce
que j'aime c'est à dire les éclairs au
chocolat les pains les chocolatines
puisque c'est pas les pains au chocolat
[Musique]
le vin très peu pas d'alcool donc je
mange des légumes je mange des fruits
des félins alors les féculents ça doit
être dissocié les féculents c'est deux
fois par semaine et c'est le soir et ce
n'est pas le midi d'accord alors que
vous ne voulez manger seul ou vous
mangez de la viande du poisson vert un
petit peu de graisse un tout petit peu
le midi jamais de graisse le soir des
féculents le soir et les fruits le soir
vous savez alors moi j'ai entendu tout à
fait l'inverse surtout pas prendre des
fruits le soir
ça marche ça marche et le matin
un petit peu de protéines
yaourt 0% pas de graisse le matin jamais
de graisse le matin pas de beurre sur
les confiture non surtout pas et pain
complet mais ça c'est des régimes ou
c'est vous qui euh
très clairement moi je suis une
diététicienne depuis des années qui m'a
donné la base et ça fonctionne parce que
je fais toujours le même poids donc ça
veut dire que vous mettez pas de sauce
dedans parce que souvent on a tendance à
se rattraper sur la sauce c'est comme le
poisson parfois il y a une petite sauce
qui accompagne c'est ça
qui est bon mais les pâtes déjà j'en
mange très peu très très peu je mange
plutôt du riz et finit la carbonara fini
tout ce que j'adore mais on m'a dit mais
bon c'est un choix
maintenant à cause de ça
parce que parallèlement j'adore les
légumes j'adore les fruits alors
autant cet espadon et rappelons quand
même que l'espadon a un nez quand même
très allongé c'est pour ça qu'on le
compare à une à une épée voilà
absolument alors cet espace
qui a du mot stade voilà alors l'espadon
c'est proche du thon mais vous vous avez
une préférence pour
vous dire même sur l'espadon non mais
c'était juste pour savoir une préférence
par rapport au temps parce que c'est pas
si éloigné que ça c'est pas c'est pas
franchement accompagner ceci dit moi
j'aime plutôt ce qui est cuit donc
l'espadon se mange cuit le thon se mange
mi-cuit voire cru donc je préfère
l'espandre alors trois choses à savoir
du coup pour cuisiner l'espadon
Jean-Pierre la première fois qu'on a
droit de l'espadon et dans cette
émission et il est très bon merci alors
c'est un poisson à chair très délicate
il ressemble on vient de le dire un peu
à celle du thon il est source de
protéines de faire de vitamines riches
en lipides et en oméga 3 il appartient à
la catégorie des poissons semi gras
comme la sardine et la macro donc comme
le maquereau donc c'est très bon pour la
santé l'espadon se pêche aussi bien dans
les mers tempéré ou tropicales donc du
coup entre la Méditerranée les océans
pacifiques atlantiques ou indiens ils se
pèche toute l'année attention quand même
l'espadon est victime de surpêche c'est
stocks sont donc bas donc comme vous
l'avez d'ailleurs justement dit
privilégiez lorsque vous êtes chez votre
poissonnier une pêche durable en regard
aussi se détestadant n'est pas en train
de dilapider les stocks de d'espadon
qui peuvent détériorer
souvent au gros vous savez les pêcheurs
adorent défier un peu un espadon qui se
bat il y a vraiment un combat un peu
titanesque entre le l'animal voilà
exactement alors il se cuisine aussi
bien au barbecue à la poêle au four même
s'il est préférable un peu de le faire
mariner au four parce qu'il peut être un
peu sec ils sont brèves dans tous les
cas un peu comme pour le ton moi je
pense qu'on peut aussi le manger un peu
rosé l'espadon mais c'est vrai qu'il
mérite il supporte davantage un peu de
cuisson il peut même se déguster cru en
carpaccio ou en CVC juste avec un peu de
sel et de citron vert
parce que la coriandre etc il y a un
certain nombre du citron de l'oignon et
donc oui c'est très bon c'est de
préparer comment si vous faites de
l'espadon chez vous alors très
curieusement
je n'en fais pas souvent parce que je
n'aime pas cuisiner le poisson
je n'aime pas cuire difficile voilà je
n'aime pas cuisiner le poisson je
cuisine beaucoup mais j'ai une cuisine
pas tellement
l'odeur j'aime pas trop alors et puis
j'ai pas forcément le temps d'aller chez
le poissonnier à une heure donnée pour
que ça soit frais et cetera donc j'en
mange plutôt à l'extérieur restant
et quelquefois à l'Assemblée nationale
d'ailleurs parce que nous en servent et
alors vous aimez cuisiner quels sont vos
plats signatures comme on pourrait dire
la signature alors moi j'ai qui a eu la
chance de beaucoup voyager et qui est
vécu à l'étranger j'aime beaucoup les
choses
épicé j'aime énormément la cuisine
indienne j'aime énormément la cuisine
thaïlandaise vous avez été en Asie vous
avez beaucoup travaillé également à Bali
parce que lorsque j'étais au Costa Rica
j'allais très souvent à Bali faire
fabriquer des maillots de bain des
savons et des tas d'objets c'est une
cuisine intéressante parce que on est
indonésien mais en même temps on n'est
pas musulman on peut avoir un peu de
sport etc si on confond de plusieurs
cultures c'est absolument
intéressant donc épicé vous aimez bien
ah j'aime bien épicé j'aime bien goûter
justement lorsqu'on on est très régime
justement on met des épices pour donner
du goût vous voyez du goût
mais on met du goût alors la meilleure
cuisine du monde puisque vous avez
voyagé puisque pour vous c'est quoi
alors parlant dans l'absolu mais pour
vous alors bon la française est
extrêmement goûteuse extrêmement
élaborée ceci dit moi la cuisine
espagnole alors pourtant elle est pas
légère mais une bonne paella une fille
doit
remplir
comme une paella mais on la met au four
et ça c'est très important pour que les
petites les petits cheveux d'ange claque
Segré dressent donc on a une sorte de
coupe au carré quand vous reçois comment
semer le plat et c'est délicieux c'est à
base de poisson bien évidemment
nous on oppose cuisine espagnole
italienne vous vous préférez la cuisine
espagnole qui est pourtant un peu plus
grasse effectivement vous l'avez dit un
peu moins raffiné mais moi j'aime bien
la cuisine espagnole
mais oui parce que j'étais alors non
seulement j'ai vécu en Espagne mais par
les manches étaient marié avec un
catalan ne confondons pas les cadeaux
les Espagnols attention
et donc
effectivement ma belle-mère mon ex
belle-mère avait des restaurants alors
donc elle m'a appris à faire la paella
comme il fallait la faire la Fido a
comme il fallait la faire et surtout
quelques petites recettes à base de riz
du genre du lapin aux artichauts ce
qu'on ne mange pas du tout en France
mais qui est un pur délice donc des
choses un peu différentes donc vous
quand vous cuisinez c'est plutôt de la
cuisine espagnole
disons que j'ai un fils évidemment qui
est
entre les entre l'Espagne et donc il me
demande souvent maman maman une tortilla
maman il a 24 ans mais vous savez même à
24 ans maman tu es là quand je rentre à
Toulouse ah tu es là j'aime que tu sois
là parce que tu vas pouvoir me faire à
manger donc donc une tortilla
espagnole qui sont très bonnes mais la
paella c'est pas catalan la paella n'est
pas catalane
l'original c'est de balancer mais vous
savez qui storiquement à l'époque de
Franco il y a énormément d'espagnol pur
qui sont montés en Catalogne puisque
Franco voulait absolument que la
Catalogne s'espanyse donc
il y a énormément de doubles je sais pas
dire nationalité puisqu'ils sont tous
espagnols
parce que vous avez été charcutier
traiteur on s'improvise pas charcutier
traiteur j'imagine quel est cette
histoire ah oui c'est une histoire un
peu un peu dingue c'est à dire que
revenons du Costa Rica alors que j'avais
un musée de la tortue marine et j'avais
un complexe
éco touristique important comme j'étais
mariée donc avec un catalan je suis
revenu à Barcelone
en blanc et bien il apprécie beaucoup
donc du coup de là on a fait un peu de
traiteur il y a alors évidemment il y
avait une terrasse où on servait des tas
de choses puisque les Espagnols ne
viennent pas acheter ils viennent aussi
déguster et donc et puis vous savez que
les horaires sont très très différents
donc et ben écoutez terrasse grande
charcuterie on fait un peu de tout et
puis et puis un jour je demande à Anne
mes fournisseurs français de foie gras
de me livrer il vient et je lui dis mais
là là il y a un vrai coup à faire en
termes de traiteur puisqu'en espagnol il
y a un pouvoir d'achat énorme sur le
traiteur vous avez des mariages tous les
mariages se font entre 120 150 euros par
tête ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas en
France le budget est nettement
il y avait un marché on s'est dit mais
il faut mettre la France là parce que
qui mieux que nous pouvons
pouvons faire ce genre de choses et donc
du coup
on a monté place à des cataluny en plein
centre de Toulouse on a monté un
traiteur qui était donc la filiale du
traiteur français et
là j'en étais la directrice puisque mon
le le le patron de pas les bonnes du
tout espagnol et connaissait pas du tout
l'Espagne et je suis allé démarcher des
entreprises dont le Barça et il se
trouve qu'à l'époque responsable
communication était française et donc
allez ça c'est passé vous savez les
Français quand ils sont à l'étranger il
y a une caste française qui qui se barre
ça précisons c'est le FC Barcelone le
club mythique
et là des des des
grandes soirées extraordinaires à 1000
personnes que des vies
la direction du Barça enfin bon
grandiose budget plus ou moins illimité
qu'est-ce qu'il adore alors Messi
n'était pas là à l'époque moi j'étais à
l'époque de Ronaldinho de tilleul
il était
et en tout cas il était pas dans les
réunions voilà dans les dans l'équipe et
donc et ben là on était vraiment sur sur
les repas espagnol et français parce
qu'en fait il voulait toujours un petit
truc espagnol d'accord enfin ou catalan
alors la fille d'oie est plus catalane
donc il y avait souvent des fidroits et
puis avec des entrées plus élaborées et
des desserts plus élaborés français
parce que les Espagnols en termes de
desserts ils sont
il y avait du calamar sans doute ils
adorent ça j'adore la plancha
donc beaucoup de fruits de mer etc donc
vraiment c'était une très très belle
époque que j'ai vécu avec des soirées où
on était moi j'ai un souvenir
complètement incroyable une très grande
réception où je devais monter sur les
caisses de vin et je commandais 54
cuisiniers et 120 serveurs j'étais sur
la caisse en train de gigoter
c'est un truc de fou c'est un truc de
fou alors pendant que vous vous mangez
encore cet espadon je vais vous parler
un petit peu du vin parce que vous nous
avez demandé à un Tariquet première
grive alors le Tariquet Premier League
c'est dans les Côtes de Gascogne c'est
un IGP Gascogne c'est 100% gros enceinte
pour le cépage et c'est un vin qui est
moelleux grâce à ce cépage là donc un
petit peu un petit peu sucré enfin demi
sec et dirons-nous le millésime c'est
2021 et son caractéristique selon les
les spécialistes c'est un nez de fleurs
de fruits blancs des touches de miel et
et d'amande et ça se marie à mon avis
assez bien avec l'espadon qui est plus
sec et le moelleux du vin c'est c'est ce
choix là c'est cet accord ou c'est
plutôt mettre en valeur aussi la
Haute-Garonne
c'est un vin que je bois mais je vais
vous dire il y a une vraie raison
c'est à dire qu'en fait quand j'étais
prêteur du Barça on leur a fait
découvrir ce vin et on le servait très
régulièrement parce qu'il l'adorait et
en fait moi j'adore ce vin j'ai plutôt
le palais sucré plutôt naturellement et
il est moelleux il est extraordinaire
c'était un vin qui était complètement
inconnu et aujourd'hui à Toulouse et
d'ailleurs même à Paris
mais au départ c'était c'était vraiment
dans le sud le Tariquet et et puis
maintenant tout le monde boit du temps
parce que il y a quand même 1125
hectares de vignes de Tariquet donc
c'est un énorme domaine il faut le dire
et neuf à 10 millions de bouteilles qui
sortent par an d'ailleurs le prix
ça reste abordable parce que c'est
évidemment très largement répondu mais
au début c'était plutôt dans le sud et
ça va facile vous qui nous avait dit
j'aime pas tellement le vin c'est vrai
que c'est un vin facile ceux qui veulent
découvrir le vin je pense qu'ils peuvent
commencer par un petit arrêté moelleux
comme ça pour ce alors le Tariquet plus
classique et sec alors que le premier
grive est un petit peu plus moelleux
pour la perritif le foie gras justement
exactement c'est bien exactement alors
on va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollable maintenant c'est le quiz
alors vous l'avez déjà dit au Costa Rica
vous êtes penché au chevet de ces
tortues menacées une espèce protégée
mais attention toujours cuisiner
seriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations au sujet de la tortue à
table son vrai ou fausses on va aller
voir à l'écran le goût de la tortue
ressemble à celui de la baleine alors la
vraie ou faux c'est une sacrée question
parce que moi vous pensez bien que j'ai
jamais mangé
de tortue de temps en temps
mais alors donc
oui vous avez raison alors moi j'ai pas
entendu dire lapin c'est plutôt poulet
ou veau et il y en a qui disent aussi ça
peut de temps en temps aussi avoir un
petit goût de poisson mais les échos
c'est plutôt poulet d'accord
deuxième la première recette de Turtle
soupe
qui faisait fureur en grande robot train
date de 1721 la Turtle soupe c'était un
must
c'est possible ça oui je dirais vrai
bravo incollable sur la tortue la tortue
de Kawan a la purée de tomate et aux
œufs durs est une spécialité japonaise à
la purée de tomates et aux œufs durs est
une spécialité japonaise mais c'est
surtout le nom de la tortue qui est
important la tortue Kawan
la fameuse sauce tortue est à base de
fois de tortue de tomates et de
gingembre
la fameuse sauce tortue qu'on voit dans
la cuisine française parfois on voit
bien non oui vous avez raison parce que
il y a effectivement du madère du jambon
du poivre mais il y a pas de tortue donc
la sauce tortue s'appelle tortue
alors maintenant on va parler foot
puisque vous avez assuré le service
traiteur pour pour le club de Barcelone
est-ce que vous nous sauriez nous dire
dans quel stade de France sont consommés
ces spécialités alors à la galette
saucisse
il faut connaître un peu le foot alors
figurez-vous je suis un petit peu plus
rugby que foot
galette je pense que c'est il faut
s'arrêter sur galette si je peux vous
donner la galette on l'appelle aussi
crêpes ah ouais d'accord alors ouest on
va dire Bretagne
les équipes de foot de la Bretagne
ah d'accord alors B le sandwich à
l'andouillette
de 3 donc
à l'est c'est les la trois c'est pas les
non c'est les deux trois c'est sûr moi
j'ai trouvé une autre sandwich je sais
pas s'il y a trois ils font du sandwich
mais alors c'est le stade de l'Olympique
Lyonnais ah oui bah oui c'est possible
à Lyon alors après il y a les frites au
gras de bœuf
S
sont pensionnat plutôt oui oui
et alors dernier le sandwich à l'aïoli
alors ça ça doit être Sud est-ce sud-est
une grande ville une grande ville
allez bravo alors vous savez qu'en
France le repas occupe une assez large
place et particulièrement en politique
c'est souvent l'axe nous les deals et
que se fait la petite et la grande
histoire alors c'est la brève de
comptoir
on vous a demandé justement Corinne
Vignon de réfléchir à une histoire
autour d'un repas en politique est-ce
que vous en avez une à nous raconter
alors déjà je vous dis en général les
repas en politique ne sont pas
franchement
délirants et drôle en général c'est très
c'est très normé on va dire lorsqu'on
est avec les ministres etc par contre
nous avons fait un repas avec la
Commission à faire sociale allez enfin
c'était le mandat précédent
et nous faisons un repas c'était plutôt
un repas de fin de mandat et donc nous
étions avec la présidente de la
commission à faire sociale Brigitte
bourguignon à l'époque et puis tous les
députés nous étions dans un restaurant
un soir et est arrivé à ce moment-là
Olivier Véran Olivier Véran était à
l'époque ministre de la Santé ce qui
n'est plus même si les Français pensent
qu'il est toujours d'ailleurs
un autre point il est arrivé et c'était
une totale surprise personne ne le
savait mais il avait eu des infos etc il
est arrivé et donc on a commencé à
discuter et à un moment donné on a
demandé au patron de nous mettre un
karaoké et j'ai attrapé Olivier Véran
par le bras et je lui ai fait chanter
paroles et paroles et paroles et je
jouais Dalida et je l'ai dit
mais attendez pas du tout moi non plus
d'ailleurs ça a été plutôt un coup de
c'était sur le moment et donc et ben
j'ai mis même doigts dans les cheveux
et lui était en train de me dire je
t'aime tu es belle etc comme dans la
chanson
on a vraiment rien donc c'est un moment
qui était sympathique plutôt que
certaines discussions qui quelquefois je
vous l'avoue peuvent être un petit peu
pesantes allez on avance dans cette
émission et on va parler des des petites
portions de nourriture autour d'un verre
de vin vous allez voir vous connaissez
c'est le modèle espagnol des tapas qui
est une tradition bien sûr qui s'exporte
et c'est le dessous des plats
brigitte c'est le totem de la cuisine
espagnole c'est tapas cette petite
portion de pâte à tasses ou de tortillas
que l'on déguste souvent debout un
Debard en barre alors comment et où
peut-on déguster des tapas en France
reportage à Paris de Baptiste Chartier
janutin
voici les tapas des petites bouchées à
base de nourriture simple où élaboré
chez ce traiteur du septième
arrondissement on opte pour la touche
raffinée ici le chef est aux petits
soins
[Musique]
originaire de Séville Alberto et rice
dirige ce restaurant depuis 3 ans kata
passe au menu par jour lui veut
transmettre la tradition dit-il faire
voyager ses clients tout en y ajoutant
ça touche personnelle
c'est le même milieu
et avec les meilleurs produits et le
pari semble bel et bien réussi
oui on retrouve ce qu'on les tabac
stèles qu'on peut les connaître en
Espagne avec cette diversité très
centrée aussi sur les légumes sur voilà
les plus cuits et c'est ça qui est
formidable c'est d'être à Paris et
malgré tout de vivre ces spécialités qui
évoluent avec un chef qui est très
attentif mais en Espagne l'état passe
sont avant tout un mode de vie qui se
transmet de génération en génération en
témoigne ces images au comptoir
dans cet autre restaurant parisien c'est
cette convivialité contente de
reproduire dans les fourneaux on
s'active qu'est-ce qu'on fait le bon
je vais
pouvoir
mi-cuit ton rouge de quoi aller chez la
clientèle
ici les tapas ne sont pas dégustés au
comptoir malgré tout c'est l'esprit de
partage qui prime bah on se lève un peu
on va piquer à la pâte à tasse bravo ce
qui est à côté ou alors elle a croqué de
l'autre côté et puis on partage un peu
une sensation gustative tous ensemble et
les clients à pro
et on est plus dans la découverte on
peut échanger nos commentaires sur la
nourriture puisqu'on goûte à la même
que sur son plat du coup on va avoir une
variété en fait assez sympa quoi
emblème de la tradition culinaire
espagnole en France il faut compter en
moyenne 25 euros par personne pour une
soirée tapas
Corinne Vignon vous qui avez une double
identité on l'a bien vu espagnol et
française est-ce que c'est tapas sont
solubles dans la culture française parce
que quand on voit le premier le premier
restaurant effectivement dans l'assiette
c'est 100% espagnol mais on voit ces
deux datables on n'est pas debout on
n'est pas au bar c'est pas l'ambiance
espagnole c'est pas ça les tapas
moi on essaye de le reproduire mais
quelque part on n'y est pas forcément
déjà dans les contenants déjà dans les
quantités parce que les tapas nous on
les sert presque individuellement parce
qu'il faut pas confondre tapas c'est une
chose vous savez les pins choses basques
que vous achetez et vous achetez c'est
du pain avec un tout petit tartines
et vous avez un pic et donc ce pic en
fait quand vous fait payer au pic voilà
à la fin on compte les pics dans votre
assiette et l'État passe en Espagne ce
sont des tapas plus larges qu'on partage
c'est pas forcément des parents
individuels d'autre part en Espagne on a
énormément de théorie de mer on a des
almers on a des on a des des produits
frais de la mer poulpe du poulpe poulpe
c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'extraordinaire et en France on est
plus sur les croquettes mais les
croquettes bon les croquettes c'est
clairement congelés et alors que les
vrais coquettes que l'on fait à la main
ça prend des heures puisque c'est de la
béchamel fous des cantiques et le poulet
enfin bon et cetera alors là c'est des
croquettes courgettes les patates
patates bah c'est des pommes de terre à
la sauce bon d'accord on sait pas faire
que on
a parlé c'est une question de cuisine ou
c'est une question de d'habitude de mode
de vie comme on le disait
c'est c'est un mode de vie que nous
n'avons pas nous nous sommes à table
normalement nous sommes à table avec
couteau elle mange leur tapas à table à
6 c'est pas ça l'étape non c'est pas ça
c'est pas ça donc c'est souvent sur une
terrasse l'esprit espagnol alors dans le
sud de la France on est nettement plus
proche parce que déjà on est beaucoup
plus dehors
et et il y a aussi une chose c'est que
en Espagne les horaires sont
complètement différents donc l'état
passe ne sont pas forcément un repas
nous on mange on vient on prend l'apéro
mais en fait on mange complètement les
tapas alors qu'en Espagne pas du tout on
en fait pas du tout un repas après
normalement il y a les tapas et ensuite
vous avez la viande
en fait on est à l'envers en nous on
mange la par exemple la viande avec des
légumes en Espagne on a les tapas qui
sont ce qui sert de légumes en fait et
ensuite on mange la viande mais très
curieusement on la mange toute seule
c'est à dire vous demandez un steak vous
avez une assiette vidéo
donc on peut se déplacer on peut se
déplacer aller manger l'état passe
dehors et ensuite rentrer ou alors on va
vous débarrasser les tapas on n'a pas
c'est plutôt l'apéro alors l'apéro
espagnol les tapas sont piquore des
petits trucs et puis après on va à table
exactement
ça pourrait servir d'entrée en fait ça
sert d'entrée alors que nous
préliminaires on est on va au resto et
on mange des tapas
en Espagne c'est vraiment la tradition
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a plus de bar à
tapas que de restaurant oui
la tapas c'est où tous les restaurants
il y a les mêmes et à la même la même
chose sur le bocadio le bocadio c'est le
sandwich
tous les Espagnols à 10h du matin
partent du bureau et puis ce qui
commence plutôt et ils vont manger le
bocadir le bocadillo donc le le le
sandwich avec du fromage avec du jambon
avec du chorizo avec ce que vous voulez
dedans bon et bien là c'est pareil la
tapas la tapas c'est
vers une heure vers 1h le midi vers 13h
13h30 ou c'est vers 19h 19h30 mais
ensuite il va y avoir la scénar le dîner
et donc on a mangé quelques trucs on a
picoré quelques trucs et ensuite on va
dîner ce qui est parce que le dîner
c'est à 10h30 du soir jamais avant alors
en France il y a la tradition de la
gastronomie française c'est pour ça
aussi peut-être que ça se ça
Marie pas très bien avec notre culture
française
alors les gens adorent aller manger les
tapas ils adorent mais ce qu'ils mangent
n'est pas de mon point de vue à la
hauteur de ce qui est proposé en Espagne
en tapas d'accord c'est pas assez
raffiné c'est pas assez léger c'est pas
assez léger parce que oui il y a les
patates
espagnoles c'est plein de mayonnaise
c'est pas possible
c'est bon oui c'est bon mais en général
ce sont les fruits de mer normalement
c'est des crustacés des fruits de mer
des moules des c'est ça les vrais
Barcelone mais c'est pas les mêmes à
Séville c'est pas vrai
mais en tout cas on en fera pas un repas
on fera pas un repas de tapas c'est je
n'ai jamais vu un espagnol il fait les
tapas et puis deux heures après il va
manger la paillarde vous voyez c'est pas
nous on se dit tiens on va on va manger
que ça en Espagne aussi on assiste à des
tapas un peu j'allais dire premium
maintenant avant d'être à pas c'était
très populaire on mangeait ça sur le bar
on ça valait rien maintenant on est des
tapas un peu sophistiqué avec du foie
gras même en Espagne est-ce que vous
vous critiquez un peu ce cette tendance
vous trouvez que le tapas ça doit rester
quelque chose de très populaire très
basique
l'exception le foie gras ou c'est où on
en trouve de plus en plus on en trouve
de plus en plus parce qu'il le consomme
de plus en plus
ceci dit ça ne fait pas partie des
habitudes culinaires des Espagnols il
l'adore mais ça reste ce n'est pas un
produit justement c'est pas un produit à
tapas non moi je disais foie gras mais
ça peut être aussi du jambon espagnol
très très cher et qui sur un tapas vaut
très très cher tapas à base de Ramon en
Espagne ça vaut très cher
il n'y a pas une famille moi j'ai vécu
quand même presque 7 ans en Espagne tous
les soirs tous les soirs il y a la toxia
alors qu'elle soit d'asperges qu'elle
soit de pommes de terre qu'elle soit
d'oignons qu'elle soit la tortilla il y
a Ramon jambon obligatoirement campagne
obligatoirement on ne commence pas et
derrière vous avez un poisson vous avez
une viande mais vous commencez
obligatoirement comme ça alors vous qui
aimez manger light c'est light ou pas
finalement une fois qu'on a vraiment
pas vraiment mais en général parce que
j'étais je mangeais un petit peu le bon
les œufs la question c'est de savoir
s'il y a 4 tonnes d'huile dans la
dans la tortilla et c'est souvent le cas
donc je mange un tout petit peu et le
jambon mais je retire le gras alors que
c'est le gras le meilleur
est-ce qu'il y a des dernières questions
est-ce qu'il y a des petits tapas vegan
maintenant puisque c'est la grande mode
est-ce que ça contamine ou pardon est-ce
que ça touche l'Espagne pas du tout le
végan même pas ils savent ce que c'est
même pas en rêve
on mange la viande le poisson
allez bonne transition parler du
bien-être animal vous devez être
attentive au fonctionnement des
abattoirs vous qui êtes soucieuse qui
avait travaillé dans un groupe de
travail ici à l'Assemblée pour le
bien-être animal parce que les abattoirs
ils sont souvent accusés de faire
souffrir nos bêtes alors on en parle et
on met les pieds dans le plat
musique d'ambiance box privé dans
l'abattoir de Bègles les bêtes sont
chouchoutées avant d'être abattu un
modèle qui pourrait faire Flores car au
bien-être animal s'ajoute la vente de
viande en circuit court qui plaît aux
consommateurs reportage pierre Michael
carnieres et Gilles lepêtre
le bruit d'une rivière une méthode pour
captiver ses BES avant le coup fatal
la battoir de Bègles près de Bordeaux et
l'un des premiers en France à mettre en
place une charte de bien traitant
ce que nous on fait ici c'est vraiment
attention au bien-être animal c'est à
dire que les opérateurs ont le temps de
faire les choses je suis là pour veiller
à ça sur 8 heures de travail on fait 14
têtes donc c'est vraiment on a le temps
de le faire un abattage présenté comme
plus éthique très loin des standards des
établissements industriels il faut
vraiment qu'on puisse montrer les choses
avoir une filière transparente c'est
très important je pense à de nos jours
pendant tellement d'années beaucoup de
choses ont été cachés sur la viande sur
la boucherie là il faut tout montrer et
voir qu'on travaille vraiment dans de
bonnes conditions
donc là c'est une bête de nous éleveurs
adhérents
à emmener ici pour faire abattre
découper mise au sous vide mettre en
caissette et que lui il va directement
la ferme directement à la ferme ou bien
dans l'une des cinq boucheries de la
coopérative les clients sont attentifs à
la méthode d'abattage c'est bien beau
déjà
et je pensais qu'ici c'est abattu d'un
énorme les animaux pour moi c'est
quelque chose qui me touche beaucoup
quoi le mal à l'animal c'est c'est pas
non pour 23% des Français le bien-être
animal est un combat de société
prioritaire et ça les producteurs l'ont
bien compris
le consommateur cherche aujourd'hui
certes des animaux de plein air et tout
ça mais aussi qui soit abattu dans de
bonnes conditions quand on voit des
images de L214 et tout bon c'est il y a
des images qui nous choquent aussi on
voulait être sûr en créant notre propre
outil d'abattage que les derniers
instants de nos animaux que l'on élève
avec passion soit les plus doux possible
pour eux et avec le moins de stress
possible ce modèle d'abattage reste très
minoritaire en France un secteur ou près
de 4 millions de bovins sont tués chaque
année
Corinne Vignon qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de ce modèle d’abattoir est-ce que vous
pensez que ça pourrait remplacer
l'abattoir traditionnel effectivement il
y a un énorme travail à faire sur les
abattoirs déjà je dois dire que
travailler dans un abattoir je pense
qu'il y a rien de plus horrible parce
que je pense toujours aux femmes et aux
hommes qui travaillent qui doivent qui
ont des cadences de fou et alors là je
vais en visiter un prochainement à
Saint-Gaudens où il y en a un qui va
être complètement rénové mais enfin je
connais bien le thème donc
effectivement il faut abattre les
animaux dans de meilleures conditions le
problème numéro un le transport c'est
qu'il y a de plus en plus d'abattages
qui d'abattoirs pardon qui ferment et
donc les animaux doivent faire de plus
en plus de transport ensuite ils sont
stockés
et la chaîne va les empêcher enfin ils
vont passer les uns derrière les autres
l'étourdissement s'il se fait
l'étourdissement se fait mal parce que
quand vous devez étourdir un animal au
pistolet il tint derrière les autres ils
rentrent dans des cages si vous avez un
boeuf il rentre bien dans la cage si
vous avez un ovin vous avez un mouton il
se balade partout donc il faut attraper
la bête donc il est mal étourdi il est
mal étourdi donc ils sont abattus
donc effectivement tout ce qui permettra
à nabattage plus vertueux
moi je mange de la viande je n'ai
consomme de la viande il y a pas pour
moi il y a pas de souci même si je pense
que à terme on en consommera de moins en
moins en tout cas je dois dire que nos
éleveurs sont extrêmement vertueux en
termes de bien-être animal très peu
d'élevages intensifs bon le problème
c'est le port c'est le plus gros
problème je dirais pourquoi parce que
les les truies sont élevés en cage elle
ne peuvent pas se retourner elles ne
peuvent que être debout et se coucher et
lorsque vous inséminez une truie vous la
laissez pendant trois semaines dans une
cage elle est comme ça
elle reste debout ou couchée et ensuite
lorsqu'elle va être pleine elle va
allaiter ses petits en cage les petits
ont le droit de tourner autour d'elle
mais elle ne bouge pas en plus on les
insémine et souvent on fait elles ont 14
pi et on les assimilant on fait
peut-être 16 ou 17 petits porcelets et
donc il y en a qui il y en a qui peuvent
surtout que chaque petit porcelet à la
première heure va choisir une tétine et
va toujours téter à la même tétine donc
ça veut dire qu'il y en a qui pourront
pas ok
donc les ports l'animal c'est un animal
normalement qui fouille qui fait son nid
c'est on lui donne de la passion lui
donne un environnement Richie c'est un
animal qui d'abord c'est extrêmement
intelligent un port c'est comme un chien
et donc il a besoin d'un environnement
mais évidemment ça coûte nettement plus
cher de leur donner des enrichissements
d'environnement que de les mettre en cas
et vous vous avez fait une proposition
de loi justement pour le bien-être
animal alors c'était aussi pour
permettre qu'il n'y ait plus de
d'animaux dans les cirques par exemple
pourquoi vous vous en prenez pas
justement à l'élevage des pores détruit
là qui sont une question cage alors que
on s'en prend au poulet élevé en cage
vous avez raison vous voulez pas faire
légiférer là-dessus
ici absolument mais au départ le
bien-être animal à l'Assemblée nationale
et ben c'était pas forcément le sujet
majeur ce que je comprends pas ailleurs
c'est un sujet de ce sujet de société
qui monte cela dit
globalement pour faire un texte de loi
qui passe vous pouvez pas toucher à la
chasse vous pouvez pas toucher à
l'élevage vous pouvez pas toucher la
corrida je vous le fais court mais c'est
à peu près ça et donc il fallait faire
une une proposition de loi consensuelle
qui soit votée parce que c'est le but de
la faire c'est soit voté donc maintenant
nous avons
l'orientation de l'agriculture qui
arrive et là en tant que présidente du
bien-être animal du groupe d'études du
président du bien-être animal là je peux
vous assurer qu'on va rentrer dans dans
l'élevage et il faut que là vous allez
proposer ça on va proposer
l'élevage en cage on va parler de
l'élevage en cage on va parler du
transport animalier puisque en pleine en
pleine chaleur des des mots qui sont
transportés sur des centaines de
kilomètres je vous parle pas des animaux
qui sont transportés à l'étranger c'est
pareil là c'est presque des jours de
voyage ça c'est dans les mois qui
viennent vous allez et en plus il y a
des directives européennes qui vont
s'occuper du sujet donc
et mon groupe d'études nous sommes déjà
63 de tous les deux il y a des gens de
la nippe il y a des gens du RN il y a
des gens de la majorité c'est
parfaitement transpathisant donc on va
rentrer par toutes les portes est-ce que
pour rebondir sur la première question
de Brigitte parce qu'effectivement on
aime beaucoup cet abattoir modèle mais
est-ce qu'on peut remplacer tous ces
abattoirs que vous avez décrits de façon
épouvantable par des abattoirs modèle et
arriver à fournir autant de viande que
les Français en mangent est-ce que c'est
possible ça va prendre des années des
dizaines d'années c'est très clairement
il faut des financements donc parce que
les abattoirs coûtent une petite fortune
que ces abattoirs modèles où il y a que
20 bêtes
économique sont pas aussi rentables que
c'est évidemment donc là il va falloir
vraiment subventionner les abattoirs
parce qu'on a une déficience à ce niveau
les abattoirs disparaissent les uns
après les autres les agriculteurs enfin
les éleveurs nous disent mais maintenant
on doit faire je ne sais combien de
kilomètres nos bêtes on les voit partir
dans quelles conditions comment
sont-elles abattues et on a besoin d'un
contrôle beaucoup plus fort une mesure
avait été prise c'était celle de des
caméras et d'ailleurs les graisser
justement que les camarades se passent
obligatoire alors c'était une promesse
de campagne du premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron vous avez parfaitement
raison et je dois vous dire que nous
avons fait une expérimentation et bien
il se trouve que l'expérimentation est
très positive très positive puisque au
départ en se disant on va pas filmer les
gens etc mais il se trouve que les les
abatters trouvent très très bien parce
que ça leur donne des conditions de
travail meilleure donc c'est quelque
chose qui va être vu soit au niveau
européen c'est ce qu'on va pouvoir
légiférer en tout cas on va faire des
amendements on va proposer
le traitement des bêtes dans les
abattoirs ces caméras très claires il y
avait des très clairement on a des
retours des retours et mon collègue
fallorny qui a beaucoup travaillé
là-dessus
me la confirmé juste hier soir il y a
aussi le il y a le modèle agricole dont
on parlait et le modèle des abattoirs
qui est pas rentable mais on a un modèle
qui est assez productiviste encore en
France est-ce que ce modèle là qu'on a
vu 14 têtes abattues en 8 heures ils
disent dans le reportage est-ce qu'on
peut imaginer qu'avec le modèle agricole
qu'on a toutes les bêtes qu'on a on
pourrait parvenir à ce modèle là est-ce
que ça peut coïncider
ce qui fait aussi sa réussite c'est le
fait qu'il y ait pas beaucoup de bêtes
traité que ce soit pas trop rapide
exactement exactement alors ça peut
marcher peut-être dans certains dans
certaines régions rappelons qu'en France
de l'élevage intensif c'est relativement
rare sauf pour les pores en général nos
éleveurs de bovins moi je les visites
très régulièrement ont 50 têtes
centaines 150 têtes je peux vous dire
les vaches elles sont elles sont bien il
y a aucun problème et on est
parfaitement virtueux maintenant sur la
battage il y a vraiment de gros progrès
à faire et là j'ai rendez-vous très
prochainement avec le ministre de
l'Agriculture et on va en parler très
très sérieusement parce que
malheureusement la battage à la ferme ne
marche pas il y a eu alors il y avait un
abattoir éthique qu'on avait fait un
reportage ici et il est en redressement
donc il faut trouver d'autres
alternatives dans cet abattoir modèle
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est le
maximum que l'on peut faire pour
accompagner les bêtes de façon digne à
la mort ou il y a encore des choses
qu'on pourrait améliorer parce que là on
a vu de la musique qu'est-ce qu'il y
avait aussi musique et puis moins de
stress parce que voilà c'est le stress
l'animal sans voilà il faut qu'il soit
arrivé effectivement pour qu'il arrive
avant il faut qu'il ait le temps de se
poser malheureusement il le sent
l'animal il est pas il est pas
complètement
il sait ce qui se passe mais justement
c'est essayer de le tranquilliser c'est
la chose très importante et puis ensuite
c'est le mode d'abattage parce que
effectivement les abattages sans
étourdissement vous imaginez que c'est
pas la meilleure solution en terme de
compliqué il y a le problème des
religions et des cultes mais justement
les cultes avancent parce qu'il y aurait
une possibilité ça serait dégorger
l'animal et de l'étourdir juste derrière
c'est à dire ils sont pas contre
on est en train d'avancer on est en
train d'avancer donc j'espère qu'un jour
on n'aura pas parce que c'est pas le
fait d'égorger le problème c'est le fait
de se vider de son sang et ça dure un
temps infini allez on va passer
maintenant au dessert et c'est le péché
mignon
et le dessert Brigitte avec une assiette
de fruits exotiques et exotique
j'insiste bien parce que comme ça ça
paraît assez banal mais dans le climat
hystérisé autour de la nourriture
commander un dessert constitué de fruits
qui ont fait obamo 10000 km
et ça peut en crisper certains alors
bienvenue à ces je sais pas ce qu'il y a
mangue ananas kiwork kiwi ça peut être
un peu français j'imaginais dans qu'il y
aurait peut-être aussi des goyave des
litchis des bananes mais elles ne sont
pas là mais alors vous assumez vous
Corinne Vignon l'assiette de fruits
exotiques alors qu'on aurait pu manger
des pommes et des poires de Normandie
absolument alors ce que j'ai fait je
voulais avoir un petit goût costaricien
le Costa Rica le Costa Rica des
producteurs
d'ananas d'accord et les mangues ben moi
j'en mangeais tous les jours parce que
j'avais un Mangué juste au-dessus de
chez moi donc c'était plus un côté un
côté rappel
mais ceci dit moi je mange alors sur les
kiwis vous avez vu que la production
française se développe se développe donc
là je suis plus vertueux
et donc vous nous disiez que vous
faisiez très attention à votre ligne
donc jamais de décès des fruits à chaque
repas non normalement le soir mais là
j'ai fait exception parce que
normalement en théorie j'aurais dû vous
demander du fromage blanc au yaourt mais
je ne l'ai pas fait et là le fruit le
fruit c'est un peu mes bonbons moi je
suis très sucrée donc manger des fruits
c'est comme des bonbons donc
il faut les manger le soir pour vous
normalement il faut les manger le soir
parce que parce que parce que ma c'est
du sucre on ne prend pas de sucre le
soir m'a-t-on dit moi
[Rires]
j'ai pas changé de poids depuis l'âge de
18 ans donc
vous connaissez en fait
alors quel est votre fruit exotique
préférée du Costa Rica et bien l'ananas
justement la nana j'en ai mangé et puis
alors vraiment c'est ça coûte rien quand
ça coûte 50 centimes l'ananas et qui est
vraiment vraiment mûre à ceux et c'est
un régal et la mangue je vous le dis
quand elle est vraiment que il l'arbre
que vous avez au-dessus de chez vous
mais alors en France ananas
mais je mange beaucoup de plutôt des
fruits rouges que j'adore et qui sont
parfaitement production française
et puis des pommes des oranges enfin bon
je mange absolument tous les fruits
j'adore
suivi et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
politique à table sur LC